IDO GREEN: Hello, and welcome
to GDL-IL, Google Developer
Live Israel, and thank
you for joining us.
Today we're going to speak about
startups, and I'm going
to share a few of the tips and
advices that I have after
starting six companies so far
in the past 18 years.
And if you have any questions or
comments, just please feel
free to either pass them on the
chat here or just ask them
in the end of this Hangout.
So without further ado, let me
just share with you a few
slides that I prepared.
And basically, what we're going
to cover in the next 10,
15 minutes will be some of the
main things that I see more
and more when I'm working
here with startups.
And for those of you that are in
the Tel Aviv area, I highly
recommend you to check out
campus Tel Aviv, that we are
basically devoting and helping
startup to bootstrap and to
leverage the knowledge that we
have here in Google in order
to bootstrap their initiatives
and to make sure that they are
leveraging and using the
right technologies at
the starting point.
So who am I?
My name is Ido Greene,
and I'm Developer
Advocate with Google.
You could reach me out after the
show or any time that you
have any comment or feedback
on one of the products.
We basically acting as Developer
Advocates and not as
evangelist, because we like to
devote at least 50% of our
time to listen to developers--
it could be
developers in startups.
It could be developers in
big organizations--
and to bring those comments
and feedback back into the
engineering groups.
I'm mostly focusing on
Chrome HTML5, Chrome
OS, and Cloud platforms.
And if you have any other things
that you would like to
touch on, please feel free to
ping me, and I'll try to
redirect you to the right people
that taking care of the
so many other platforms
and APIs that we
have here in Google.
I'm mostly active these
days on G+.
And you could reach me out at
plus.google.com, and then just
+greenido as one word.
And greenido as one world will
work also on Twitter, and you
could, of course, check
out my blog.
By the way, all the slides of
this show will be in the
footnotes of the Google
Developer Live event, and of
course on my blog.
So first and foremost, when we
are starting a company-- and
I'm hearing it a lot when
I'm talking with young
entrepreneurs--
basically, make sure that you
don't thinking about the exit
strategy from the beginning.
If the only thing that is
guiding you is how can I sell
this thing as soon as possible,
you're probably not
going to build it to last, as
Jim Collins said, but you're
going to build it to flop
with a high probability.
So planning for legacy or
planning to build something
that will last for many years,
much more healthy approach.
And I like this quote from
Mark Cuban, because it
emphasizes exactly what
I said, but in his
own words, of course.
A few things to keep in mind,
and that's basically, I guess,
the first step that each and
every entrepreneur needs to do
before they're starting to run
on their venture, is to do
research and thorough
research.
Today we have sites like
AngelList and many other, as
like second market and
just Google it.
But try to find if someone
is already answering this
specific pain point that
you recognize.
And keep in mind that companies
that are active and
basically are doing business in
the market, let's say for
quite nice time in the past, are
quite efficient, because
the ones that aren't efficient
aren't there anymore.
So it's not a healthy point of
view to say something like,
the company that I'm executing
against is just too slow, too
dumb, too inefficient.
Keep in mind that if the
company's active--
it might be that some cases,
there are inefficiency in big
organization, and of course you
want to tap and leverage
them, but keep in mind that in
a macro view, most companies
are quite efficient.
Technology is becoming
commodities more to emphasize
that if you are building yet
another app, or you are
launching a feature that is part
of a bigger [INAUDIBLE],
like let's say for example, a
startup that will hold all
your photos in the Cloud.
It's just yet another feature
that Facebook, G+, and many
others could and actually
now already doing it.
But let's say that they didn't
provide this specific service.
It's just yet another
feature, and this is
the last point here.
You want to try to avoid it,
because if you already worked
on it for two years and then
this big gorilla, or giant, if
you will, is executing against,
you're basically in
the path of the elephants,
and you don't want
to be in this path.
Aim for the real need.
I see more and more NGOs and VCs
and actually entrepreneurs
as well, they're trying to
emphasize this point of let's
build companies that are built
on real computer science and
not just another hack
here and there.
And I think it's very important,
because in the end
of the day, you do want to
make sure that you are
building something that
will be meaningful.
Let me try here just to make
sure that you see my screen.
And let's, again, try to share
it, because I think I saw that
you lost it.
Hopefully, you're
seeing my slide.
Coffee drinkers get it right.
Actually, I just rephrased what
DHH from 37signals said.
He spoke about drug dealers,
but I like to speak about
coffee drinkers.
And as an addicted coffee
drinker myself, I know exactly
what does it mean.
And here, we're coming to say
something like build an
amazing, great product that
people will be addicted to.
And yeah, you could give free
samples, and you could give
short espresso cups.
But in the end of the day, you
do want to make sure that your
experience, your service is
amazing, and people get
addicted to it, and they are
keep using it on a daily
basis, hopefully even
more than that.
Keep in mind that usually
efficient organizations are
actually delivering and building
themselves in a way
that they will act as efficient
as possible.
And in this case, it's just
coming to show what we learned
in "Freakonomics," that drug
dealers organization are
exactly mimicking what
McDonald's is based on in
terms of the hierarchy and how
managers are delegating
responsibilities.
And it's true in the startup
early days you don't need to
pay too much attention to it,
because each and every member
is wearing lots of
different hats.
But you do want to put
organization and structure and
objectives and [INAUDIBLE]
results and make sure that
everyone is running through
the same goals.
If you are not sure about why
users are dropping you or are
not [INAUDIBLE]
you want, just go to the drawing
boards or try to
improve and iterate quickly
on your product.
And we'll touch about
it a bit later.
Hiring the right people, I think
it's one of the most
problematical challenging
aspects.
You want to make sure that
at least the core team is
composed of people that you
really admire, people that
could do lots of things and do
it with a very high quality.
Do everything that you can
yourself in the early days.
It not only will give you more
runway, because you'll be more
efficient and you'll leverage
the cash or any other
resources that you have better,
but because it will
force you to hire and start
spending your capitalization
only when you must.
Don't pass on great people.
That's another hard lesson
that I learned myself.
Usually, those people are very
busy, very active, and when
you are lucky enough to meet one
of them, and you see that
they and your venture are on the
same page, definitely go
and do whatever you can in
order to put them on
the boat with you.
We know today that CVs and
actually any resume that
candidates will give you
composed for many years of
irrelevance.
And one of the best things here
is not only to make sure
that you are giving some
problems and see how the
candidate is thinking, but just
try to start small, and
in some cases, if the candidate
is already working
as a freelancer, it might be
better just to try before you
hire him for full time.
And that could actually make
expectation and be for the
benefit of both sides.
Empower your team.
I think that it's crucial that
the cofounders and the
management team will know that
they are there just to
delegate and make sure that
they are giving their
developers, designers, product
leads, all the [INAUDIBLE]
and capabilities in order
to build what they
think is the best.
And Jim Collins, that I
mentioned before, wrote some
several amazing books that I
highly recommend you to read,
like "Built to Last" and "Good
to Great." And he's describing
a level five leader as
the top level of the
leader it could be.
And you could think of someone
like Steve Jobs or Jeff Bezos
of Amazon as people that you
want to mimic, but behave, of
course, nicely.
Good is fine.
One of the things that we're
seeing more and more in
startups is the trying to
polish too much things.
And of course, it's always gray,
because you do want to
have this amazing,
magic experience.
But on the other side of this
equation, you do want to focus
on your most valuable
product, service.
And sometimes you just want to
get it out, get the feedback
from your users, and
then iterate and
improve it over time.
So the main point here is not
to wait two years down the
road and then put something in
the air and get real knowledge
from your users on what it does
to them, but be agile and
try to take small decisions
that are much better to
encapsulate, and then just
keep iterate on them very
frequently.
I think Google is a great
example for doing exactly
that, even in a large
organization,
not only in a startup.
In a startup, in my last
startup, we actually called
ourself more of a--
looked at ourself more as a
small car, not a small boat,
but basically you're enjoying
the ability to pivot quickly
and to move quickly.
And that's something that you
really want to grasp and take
it to your own hands an
advantage, because big
organizations are moving
much more slowly.
It's true that when they are
taking the decision and they
are moving, they are the
elephants on the path, and you
don't want to be
on their path.
But at least you could pivot
quickly and avoid them.
So the main point here is to
keep in mind that your money
that you raised and the
resources that you got are
very limited, and you probably
need more than you expect, so
try to be as efficient as
possible and execute as
quickly as possible.
When we're coming to speak about
a business and not a
startup, I think it's just
connecting us to the first
point, which is try to avoid
this la-la-land or this
ever-lasting land that some
people are living in.
And don't neglect the ability to
monetize or to leverage the
ability to have this other
side of the equation of
revenue or some kind
of revenue stream.
And I mentioned, of course, that
people that are building
just to exit are basically,
with a high probability,
building to flop.
Beliefs and reality, I
see some of the young
entrepreneurs that are coming
here to the campus, and we're
mentoring them, coming
with sentences like
the first two here.
And in most of the cases, it's
very, very far from reality.
So the only way that you confirm
yourself that you know
what your users really want is
after you launch a product,
and you have the metrics,
and you measure them.
And as you all know, you can't
manage what you can't measure,
and you do want to measure
everything and anything in
order to understand deeply
what is making your user
happy, and then iterate over
it and try to make it even
more magical.
Predicting the future or the
far future, of course, you
could see all over that people
fail tremendously in trying to
predict the near future, and
actually the far [INAUDIBLE]
greater [INAUDIBLE].
The progress and measuring
progress, there's lots of
thoughts about [INAUDIBLE]
trying to move us and shifting
us into [INAUDIBLE]
that you can predict better,
set [INAUDIBLE]
in order to accomplish them.
And then helping us be the
speedboat that we spoke about
on the last slide and respond
quickly and act quickly.
Focusing, I think, is one of
the most important aspects.
Because you have limited
resources, limited time,
limited money, you want to make
sure that you're focusing
on all the people in
your organization.
And it could be the three
co-founders are just focusing
on the same needle that
we want to move.
Passion, of course, if people
are not passionate, especially
in the core team, if you don't
see the light in their eyes,
and they don't put those 140% or
200% of effort and time and
devotion into the startup,
probably it won't be a
successful one.
And execution, execution I
think is one of the most
important aspects to consider.
Great ideas are all over, but
what's really differentiates
is the execution and how well
you execute according to your
objective [? and pure ?]
results.
Plan, of course it's a must.
And you do want to plan, and
you do want to set goals
quarterly, yearly, and probably
something above, so
everyone will be clear about
what is the North Star of your
venture, your company, and where
you want to see yourself
on the long run.
But keep attention that
everything is changing,
everything is volatile, and you
do want to be as agile as
possible, because this is one
of the strength capabilities
that you have at
the beginning.
Find good advisors.
Easy to say, really
hard to do.
But when you do find them, pay
attention that you listen and
you are able to gain and
leverage their feedback.
What to do fast?
So we spoke about those
main components.
And I highly recommend you, if
you are in the front end
development arena, and you're
producing interesting
products, services to the web,
the diagram here are coming to
emphasize that we need and are
actually changing today the
ways that we work in the past.
So basically, this diagram is
just showing us that it's a
never ending story.
We keep iterating after we're
working and launching the
first version of something.
And this is the way to make sure
that we are executing as
fast as we can.
What to avoid.
So yeah, if you're not an expert
on bikes, probably you
do want to avoid
this situation.
And in our case, when you're
coming to pitch to angel
investors, each and every
sentence here is well--
how should I put it--
is very known and
well-preserved from their side.
They know to identify it as pure
BS, and you probably want
to avoid them.
So our product will go viral,
because we're doing x or y.
You want to pay attention and
to make sure that you have a
good plan because in most
of the cases, it won't.
No one else is doing,
probably it's a bad
sign and a red flag.
Because if no one doing
it, probably
there is a good reason.
Try to think about successful
companies that you know and
amazing ventures that you see.
In most of the cases, they did
have some competitors at the
early days.
And there's lots of
examples on that.
Projections are conservative.
Well, you could smile when
you're saying it.
And all the others are also
very, very good points.
And as I mentioned, large
companies might be too small
or too big or too whatever, but
you need to come with real
arguments why it's viable niche
or why you could execute
much better than the current
competitors.
And on the other side of the
equation, for investor, when
you're seeing one of these,
probably a flag should
rise in your eyes.
And each and every sentence here
is quite well-known and
quite common, unfortunately.
As you all know, VC or a
typical angel will see
hundreds of startups and
entrepreneurs, and then they
will invest in, I don't
know, a dozen or less.
So the probabilities that you
will be able to raise money
are quite low.
And some of the things here
are quite common.
And actually try to just go and
put your efforts and move
on with other investors
or VCs.
Some resources that I highly
recommend you to check out.
If you want to see what the
Google Cloud Platform is
offering entrepreneurs these
days, this is the link on
cloud.google.com.
Any other materials that we have
today for startups and
entrepreneurs and developers
are on
developers.google.com/startups.
For the entrepreneurs that want
to launch and start new
businesses, there's an amazing
[INAUDIBLE] series from
Stanford, and it's in
Entrepreneurship Corner.
And it's great, great ability
to listen to thought leaders
and amazing entrepreneurs that
did it and to learn and gain
from their experience.
And some blogs that I personally
really like, AVC,
of course Fred Wilson from
Twitter fame and lots of other
companies like Foursquare of
course, and Paul Graham from Y
Combinator and Ben Feld, all of
them are great, great angel
investors, VC investors, and
of course people that write
extremely well.
If you have any questions,
please feel free.
Right now, it's a great
opportunity.
And if not, just ping me on
G+ or through my blog.
Thank you very much, and
until next Wednesday,
be strong and happy.